what's going on reject nation i
am greg ah i'm john we're gonna watch
this great video
i'm assuming great from the channel
called the things
actors forced to face their worst fears
during filming i'm a big fan of facing
your fears false evidence
appearing real something a friend of
mine named john
kramer once told me speaking of john
kramer
spiral guys the uh what an eighth
installment from this is the
book of songs actually yeah
ninth seventh jigsaw and now spyro right
we did it we did it yeah that's right
they're collaborating here
in the video so we can do that when are
you gonna get to part nine so we can
finally shout you guys out
the book is saw spiral available
wherever you can rent a movie
and john and i we actually were big fans
of the soft franchise so we were pretty
excited to be like yeah of course we'd
love to shout you guys out
we saw it in the theaters we had a
really really fun time with this movie
surprisingly
more fun than i expected it to be and
also disgusting and gory and gross in
all the ways
you're hoping first rock is funny and it
also has a bit of a seven vibe
to it but a movie like spiral that sets
your characters up in these contraptions
where
you have to face something within
yourself that's physically scary to
overcome that's kind of like every actor
i'm assuming is gonna be in this video
so guys spiral available video on demand
at greg's home john's home is playing
here
on loop watching it every two hours
we pay for it ourselves you guys should
do the same thing too
check out spiral from the book of songs
anyway let's watch this video
i know i seem really tough but i am
afraid of heights yeah
one thing i'm afraid of action heroes
and huge stars
might seem like they live there that's
offensive absolutely no
fear but it turns out that even the
biggest celebs aren't brave about
everything that's right a ton of actors
are stricken with some very serious
phobias
but the best ones never let that stand
in the way of their dreams
even if their dream job is deep
underwater or at the top of a
terrifyingly tall building
these amazing actors pushed through
their phobias and conquered them for
their most i got a horse
i'm really glad that i went through the
process of auditioning because i felt
like okay
i really i earned this now you might
think that someone who has been an
a-list celebrity since they were nine
years old like emma watson
fears nothing but when it came time to
audition for belle in beauty and the
beast
one huge fear almost made her throw in
the towel
singing emma hadn't sung since she was
12
and was absolutely terrified of having
to sing in front of anyone
let alone millions and millions of fans
she even hated doing karaoke
that was mildly terrifying but knowing
that her dream job was on the line
she leaned into her fear challenged
herself and completely conquered awesome
you know i wish i could say well uh hold
up here so
damn so she conquered a fear and got one
of the biggest
roles in like a disney million dollars
yeah man geez that's inspiring
absolutely
i know some like real singers
criticized what she did before
you know what for people like me like
sam
watson did a pretty great job
especially for not singing ostensibly
for so many years and being terrified to
even
approach the role that's yeah i'm glad
she was bold of her to audition so that
way she feels
you know yeah that's a that's a smart
way to go about it like okay
i audition so because audition they
picked me post audition that must mean
i'm right for the job
that's what the audition process
is is what i have described for you you
know i wish i could say it was
a little fluffy to do but it was that
intense if we already had a fear of
tight enclosed spaces
we probably wouldn't jump at the chance
to make a movie about being buried alive
but that's exactly what ryan reynolds
did in 2010's buried
if you don't remember the entire movie
takes place inside a sealed coffin
with reynolds trapped inside during the
show during his deadpool jokes
safe words that he would shout to be
pulled out if he needed it
but the majority of the spanish speaking
crew didn't always understand
the shoot was so rough that he says he
was both physically and
emotionally changed after filming
finished and the last day of shooting
was uh
was unlike anything i've ever
experienced in my life and i love
watching just those little snippets of
serious actor ryan right
yeah watching all the like bombastic
snarky comedy like wiped from him even
in just the interview process you know
where he
constantly has that sort of aura about
him yeah and then here
it's he's really showing like you know
this is a traumatized
yeah but damn yeah i miss i miss this
ryan reynolds
he's brilliant in this movie he's
absolutely brilliant
it's a damn good film if you haven't
seen it i feel like it bodes well for
you if there's an actual fear and you
got to be an actor and do it
that's right he's so real if you're
afraid of this that's great yeah
part of it is to be afraid even though
anthony mackie's marvel character falcon
does
a lot of flying it turns out that the
actor actually has one huge fear of his
own
height no way that means that every time
he had to soar through the air
or leap off of a tall building no way
totally terrified every single time
one time he even had to leap off of a
bridge and land right on top of a car
sure he had wires to make sure he lived
there
still there that's so cool
yeah dude you captain america and that's
even harder because at least for someone
like ryan reynolds it's like okay you
can put that all into the role but for
anthony mackie you got to pretend like
this is just
any other day for you this is where your
confidence is where you shine
that's awesome yeah yeah i know it's
easy to chalk up like oh they got wires
it's even no it's still
you're still doing a high falling i'm
afraid of heights but when i go on a
roller coaster i'm terrified yeah you
know and most of the time people don't
die on roller coasters
but once in a while they do due to
high blood pressure or
or malfunctions what
you know the bit's over we're going to
jump cut to right when i say what then
we go into the video
editors right yeah yeah yeah i mean like
we learned horse riding i don't know if
you've done it before
but um yeah robert pattinson had to
interact with a lot of animals for the
2011 film i'm afraid of horses and
fridge wraps
giant elephants that made him nervous it
was the horses
it turns out that the actor has a
long-standing fear of horses
that's crazy particular freaked him out
the most in it he had to get knocked
over by a full-grown stallion
and he did not have a good time on set
that day
i'm excited for robert pattinson to be
batman now
yeah especially can't handle horses but
he can handle all the crime in gotham
yeah let's hope that we get batman upon
a horse in this game
no style it's happened before yeah let's
do it again
yeah terrified of riding rusty
i hate it apparently fear of horses
runs in the twilight family because
rob's co-star kristen stewart
also hates being around the four-legged
giants during snow white and the
huntsman she knew that she was going to
have to learn to ride but it was
terrified at the thought they're afraid
of horseshoe lessons and worked with
some of the best trainers in the world
she never really got over her fear and
said that she
never wanted to ride again after the
shoot was over
what that's crazy some of you offered
horses everyone's afraid of something
shailene woodley has said that she is
very afraid of heights
but actually loves leaning into her
fears in order to get the adrenaline
rush that she
loves so when it came time that's why i
kill people ferris wheel in chicago for
divergent
she ran into the challenge head-on even
though she was freezing cold and very
uncomfortable
she loved the experience and used that
fear to help push herself to the top
see to me that's inspiring because the
only way you can really grow
is to face your fears i once heard an
acronym false evidence
appearing real only way to grow is step
outside of your comfort zone people
yeah be like shalane woodley be like
shalane woodley
and robert pattinson go pet a horse yeah
not kristen stewart though
no no no gave up the scariest stunt i
did
i did a 20-foot free-fall jump rebel
wilson might be completely fearless when
it comes to her comedy
but when it comes to heights that is an
entirely different story
so in pitch perfect 3 when she and anna
kendrick had to do a 20-foot free-fall
she needed a little help from her friend
according to rebel anna
really did that job i suppose and what
did she sing
well have a listen she was like go into
the chat
[Laughter]
emma roberts is hollywood royalty but
that doesn't mean that she isn't human
just like the rest of us
and when she was young her stage fright
was so bad that she almost didn't land
her breakout role as addie singer and
unfabulous
she was way too afraid to sing in public
but found comfort in the safety of a
film set
even now she says she could never do a
play or a live musical because she is
too nervous to perform on stage
i was in an episode of unfabulous dude
was she afraid
not near you no no no she was uh
she i won't say anything she was super
kind to you and you've remained friends
to this day
yeah she totally went out of her way to
get to know me and she was really big
into your appearance on it's always
sunny in philadelphia and it was like a
big fan
yeah based off that she definitely
introduced herself to me yeah
even though she had to knock me over at
one point she was
made sure to really go out of her way to
say hi i'm emma
okay cool so how are we doing this she
didn't have a
complaint to the stunt coordinator about
how she thinks i should just fall on the
stairs without ever talking to me
directly
wow but i did do the request she had
just because you you figured that's what
she might want i didn't overhear her
loudly in front of me without ever
looking at me because she respects
extras and all supporting casting stars
and ghost
i'm sure she's different now yes
your mind knows that it's not real but
your body doesn't know that you're not
going through something really awful
sarah paulson's real-life fear is so
strange and intense that ryan murphy
actually decided to write it into the
storyline of american horror
but addict in the season paulson's
character
and sarah herself suffer from something
called trypophobia
which is actually the fear of small
clusters of holes
and while it might sound strange to some
of us it turns out that around 16
percent of people suffer the same fear
that was the episode what i said i've
done watching american horror story
oh good one dude that first episode that
season because you were so scared of her
trip
yeah i was like i can't handle the
triple phobia i have nothing to do with
the quality of the filmmaking or writing
absolutely not the phobia man that's
where is that
american horror story is always
consistent as is everything ryan murphy
produces man what a dick move by
mr murphy yeah we get a good performance
out of her
in the best season of american horror
story with this movie there was one well
there was one thing that i ended up
having to do but i didn't want to do it
we usually see aubrey plaza as someone
who doesn't care what other people think
and close because her character in the
to-do list would be seen in all kinds of
compromising positions she was downright
terrified
so much so that every single day of
shooting brought up a new wave of
serious anxiety
luckily she was able to rely on the
support of her director and castmates to
help her get through some of the most
adult situations i mean yeah you like to
do nudity
this thing is it like just lives forever
now yeah
then it becomes a google search and it
gets clipped and it's yeah it's
contextualizing like it's perfect on it
yeah
everything yeah that would be i feel
like a
fear and some type of rite of passage
for literally any actor for the most
part
doing a nude scene is is intense scene
oh i thought she was just
generally afraid of taking her clothes
oh of ever being naked
i thought that's what they were yeah
aubry plaza showers clothed
she does everything clothes if she can
that's what i have
come to know because she's my friend and
she tells me this i'm moving on now john
please do
please please go please move on i never
will do that again
for her oscar-nominated turn in the
harrowing movie cake
jennifer aniston had to face one of her
biggest fears
going underwater see when jen was only
five years old she accidentally drove
her tricycle into her family pool
and sunk all the way to the bottom after
that the idea of being submerged in
water became her biggest fear
over 30 takes to work up the courage to
let herself sink underwater on set
wow wow to shoot that scene matt damon
matt damon has played all kinds of
action heroes
but it turns out that his biggest fear
in the world is snakes
maybe he should give indiana jones a try
i hate
snake shark i hate him scarlett
johansson
revealed that while filming their
heartwarming film we bought a zoo
damon actually cried a little bit when
faced with the idea of handling the
slithery creatures
but because the kids in the film and
scar joe insisted he wound up working
with the snakes and facing his biggest
fear
my legs didn't work i was just like
wow dude i have something in common with
matt dave and
we're both action heroes yeah and now
you're both oscar-nominated writers and
actresses yeah yeah you both are good
friends with ben affleck
so much in common dude i recently
held a snake for the fir roll that
footage i'm probably looking very
similar to how i look now
this is a little boy his name is diego
and this is his mom
her name is vanessa whoa
oh i'm so terrified oh my gosh oh
it's cute hello
this is this is a really strange feeling
yellow feels like a reptile i've
literally conquered a fear
today yeah dude you should be in this
list
just seeing that again it was like no
i'm not doing ever doing that
so you're not gonna matt damon it up go
with like five snakes next time millions
of dollars i wore rivers to do that i'm
not doing that
even though she gave matt damon a hard
time for being afraid of snakes
scarlett johansson has a funny animal
phobia of her own
birds the actresses said that she really
doesn't like their
beaks and wings and the way that they
move that's a bird
but in we bought a zoo she had to
overcome her phobia to film scenes
around lots of birds
the ones that she refused to go near
however peacocks
so when she like drives on the road and
she's like they're out there
yeah they're out there man she's living
life in a hitchhiker
just oh no they're all gonna die and
[ __ ] me at any moment
get that away from me what is paparazzi
no there's more birds
birds on the wire over there do you
think she has like a traumatic moment
every time someone mentions the peacock
app
because that like why the peacock why is
that the one bird she wouldn't go
near peacock at pa
the joke that's okay yep yep yep i
expect a full review of every joke after
they're complete
don't worry i won't there's only one
more one more on this list that day
so fun working with animals scarlet
isn't the only celeb with an aversion to
the big winged creatures either
even though jake gyllenhaal didn't go
into prince of persia with a fear of
ostriches
by the time he left it was a full-on
phobia
the handlers reminded him one too many
times not to make
noise near the big birds because they
could tear out your eyes and rip
out your heart so when it came time to
film the scene where he is chased by a
pack of them
the fear in his eyes was all real
that sounds like a fear everyone not a
adapter if you're about to be be set
upon by many ostriches
which you've just learned can like gore
you to death like i would be horrified
because it's like a bull run you
understand like i can see it the bull
the power it all makes sense whereas an
ostrich you could easily make that
mistake of like
that'll be fine boy how scary i always
thought ostriches were like
fun cute animals nah they don't bury
their heads in the sand
until they run out of options for
someone who has starred in movies like
charlie and the chocolate factory and
alice in wonderland
it seems odd that johnny depp would be
afraid of clowns
but he is have you heard of his ex-wife
charlie in the chocolate factory
how does he deal with his fear in the
most johnny depp way possible
by surrounding himself with clown
paraphernalia to ward off the evil
why not exposure therapy i can see that
face their biggest fears like shailene
woodley climbing to the very top of a
ferris wheel
it makes us feel like we can do the same
though
you know maybe tomorrow
but we want to know what is your biggest
fear that you would face for your dream
job
it's true if these celebrities can face
their fears
then if i get paid a few million dollars
to face my fear surrounded by a crew of
people to provide my safety
i could face my fears too it's amazing
how much trauma
you can overcome at the incentive of
millions of dollars and a posh crew
whose entire job it is to be there to
look after
your performance that is awesome
yeah man i'm sticking my head in a
crocodile tomorrow
yes do it any part that's my fear
my head chopped off by a crocodile good
good yeah
guys have you ever stuck your head
inside of a crocodile's mouth leave your
thoughts down below hey subscribe to the
things i really enjoy their list videos
a hell of a lot they're quick
snappy you don't even realize the
transition's coming makes it easy for us
to edit the way we do our reactions
but no genuinely speaking i think what
they do are wonderful
videos so subscribe to them and uh
hey let's do a pic
deontay we both were feeling doing your
name for this
and uh i'm just more curious to know
what job had in mind
well i finally learned what a tongue
punch is and it's something a lot of
people would be afraid to do
especially on someone's part of us but
not you deontay what's a tongue punch
a tongue punch it's actually to explain
it in a way that won't get us in trouble
well i assume you probably apply a
certain amount of rigidity
to your tongue muscles you know you
activate them and then you use them to
stimulate uh you know yeah
areas and uh you know especially certain
areas where
fart boxes might be applicable are you
probably need a punching motion
to really get in there because you know
rimman's big with the kids these days
so deontay i just i applaud your courage
because
a lot of people still are not down with
that and uh
you know you're out here loud and proud
and i mean all tongue punchers don't
want the fart
oh that's some punch the box some punch
the front box yeah
or the back box or the back box okay i
just don't want to
fart to have too much yeah
not right when you're in there we kept
this pg-13 youtube so
we did everything we could